My wife told me about this thing that-- honestly, this is news to me. You know when it's like the height of summer and you go out, and a feeling when the sun is just like really hot and hitting your skin and making you all warm? She likes that feeling. She likes the way that feels.
我妻子告诉我一件事——老实说，这对我是新闻。你知道当盛夏时节你走出门，阳光非常炙热地照在皮肤上，让你感到全身暖洋洋的那种感觉吗？她喜欢那种感觉。她喜欢那种触感。
And I don't know what this says about me, but the notion that anybody would like that had never occurred to me. Totally eye opening because I have never been into that feeling at all. To me, the heat of summer is just something you had to get through. It was like rain, but less wet.
我不知道这说明了我什么，但有人会喜欢那种感觉这种念头，我从来没想过。这完全让我大开眼界，因为我从来都不喜欢那种感觉。对我来说，夏天的酷热只是你必须忍受的事情。就像下雨，只是没那么湿而已。
And since she said this, this summer I've been trying to practice it. I've been trying to reprogram my own experience of the summer. And so when I'm outside, I consciously tell myself, the sun's hitting me. I'm going to enjoy this, get into it. And I can kind of get myself there for a little while. And then I lose it. I can't hold onto it. I just think that some of us really love the summer. And it is not something that you can force.
自从她说了这件事，今年夏天我一直试着去练习。我一直试图重新编程自己对夏天的体验。所以当我走在外面时，我有意识地告诉自己，阳光照在我身上。我要享受它，沉浸其中。我可以让自己维持一会儿。然后我就又不行了。我无法保持那种状态。我只是觉得，有些人是真的热爱夏天。而这种事是你无法强求的。
A couple weeks ago here on our radio show, we all saw this article about somebody like that. He's a 66-year-old lifeguard who's suing New York State for age discrimination. And I just want to pause on that for a second, a 66-year-old lifeguard.
几周前，在我们广播节目里，我们都看到了这篇关于某个像那样的人的文章。他是一位66岁的救生员，因为年龄歧视起诉纽约州。我想在这里停一下，66岁的救生员。
All of us here on our staff, we had no idea that could even exist. We all thought lifeguarding is something that you do when you're in high school, maybe a couple years after, into your 20s. Who is still lifeguarding at 66?
我们所有员工都没想到这竟然会存在。我们都以为救生员是高中生做的事，或者毕业后做几年，二十岁出头。谁会在66岁还当救生员？
And then it was even more of a question when we realized the lifeguard in the story, he has another job. He's a lawyer. He's a working lawyer.
然后当我们意识到故事里的这位救生员还有另一份工作时，这就更令人费解了。他是一名律师。他是一位在职律师。
His name is Roy Lester. He's a bankruptcy attorney. He's got his own firm in Long Island. And then he lifeguards every weekend in the summer.
他叫罗伊·莱斯特（Roy Lester）。他是一位破产律师。他在长岛有自己的事务所。然后他夏天每个周末都去做救生员。
And today on our program, we have stories of people like him, people who love the summer, not people like me. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We prepared today a program to listen to with the sun beating down on you, the humidity through the roof, a show of people embracing summer and everything about summer. And let's just get right to it with Act One.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲讲像他这样的人的故事，那些热爱夏天的人，而不是像我这样的人。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天准备的节目适合在烈日当头、湿度爆表的时候收听，这是一档关于拥抱夏天以及夏天一切事物的节目。让我们直接进入第一幕吧。
Act One, The Grapes of Wrath. So one of our producers, Dana Chivvis, she went out to Long Island and met that guy, Roy Lester, the 66-year-old attorney lifeguard who was suing New York State. Basically the deal is that they tried to make him wear a Speedo. He refused. He lost his job. Here's Dana.
第一幕，《愤怒的葡萄》。我们的一位制作人达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）去了长岛，见到了那个叫罗伊·莱斯特的66岁救生员律师，他起诉了纽约州。事情的基本情况是他们试图强迫他穿三角泳裤。他拒绝了。他丢了工作。下面有请达娜。
If you ask Roy, why are you still lifeguarding at 66, he barely understands the question. It's so self-evident to him. It's been his life since he was 16. He and his buddies were kings of the beach. He lived with other lifeguards. His best man at his wedding was a lifeguard. Their kids grew up playing together on the beach while they were on duty. He never wanted to leave this job. Even when he went to law school in California, he came back to lifeguard every summer.
如果你问罗伊，为什么你66岁了还要当救生员，他几乎听不懂这个问题。对他来说这太不言自明了。从16岁起，这就是他的生活。他和伙伴们曾是海滩之王。他和其他救生员住在一起。他婚礼上的伴郎也是救生员。他们的孩子在他们值班时在海滩一起长大。他从未想过放弃这份工作。即使在加州读法学院时，他每年夏天也会回来做救生员。
In law school, aren't you supposed to have an internship in a law firm or something like that?
在法学院，你不是应该去律师事务所实习之类的吗？
You're supposed to.
本该如此。
Did you not do that?
你没去吗？
No, I did not do that. I never took it quite that seriously. The idea of giving up the summer was something I just couldn't do.
没，我没去。我从没把那件事看得那么重。放弃夏天这种事我实在做不到。
He's not alone. At Jones Beach, where he worked for 40 years, there are dozens of guys-- teachers, firemen, police-- who stayed with it into their 60s. Lifeguarding at Jones Beach is such a thing that a former lifeguard made a film about it. It's called Jones Beach Boys .
他不孤单。在琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），他工作了40年的地方，有几十个这样的家伙——教师、消防员、警察——他们一直坚持到60多岁。琼斯海滩的救生员工作就是这样一种存在，以至于有位前救生员专门拍了一部关于它的电影。它叫《琼斯海滩男孩》（Jones Beach Boys）。
Roy insisted I watch it. I did. It was awesome. Here's my favorite song from it.
罗伊坚持让我看。我看了。真是太棒了。这是我里面最喜欢的一首歌。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
"We're going for the rescue and getting to the victim." I never really appreciated how thrilling lifeguarding is until Roy talked about rescues. We were sitting in his law office.
“我们准备去营救，靠近受害者。”在罗伊谈到营救之前，我从未真正领会过救生员的工作有多刺激。我们当时坐在他的律师事务所里。
The exhilaration of a good rescue is unlike anything you've ever had. And you don't get that. I sit here, and I shuffle papers. I wouldn't call it exciting. I wouldn't call it rewarding.
那种成功营救后的兴奋感是你从未体会过的。而你得不到这种感觉。我坐在这里，只是在处理文件。我不会称其为令人兴奋。我也不会称其为有成就感。
But this is-- you're actually accomplishing something. You're up there, and all of a sudden you're going out in the water, and the rest of the world is behind you. There's nothing else except between you getting from your stand to that victim. That's the only thing. And it's great. It's a great feeling.
但这种工作是——你确实完成了什么事情。你站在那里，突然你就冲进水里，世界其他一切都被抛在脑后。除了你从瞭望塔冲向受害者之间，什么都不存在。就是这样。这感觉棒极了。
How many people do you think you've rescued in your career?
你觉得你职业生涯里救过多少人？
Over 1,000.
超过1000个。
1,000?
1000个？
Yeah. You have to remember. There were times we would have 40 rescues in an hour.
对。你要记住。那时候我们有时候一小时就要进行40次营救。
What? Why? What? Who? Why?
什么？为什么？什么？谁？为什么？
Because you have people that come down to Jones Beach who really don't know about swimming, especially when you have a current. And you can get a very strong current at Jones Beach.
因为来到琼斯海滩的人很多并不真正懂游泳，特别是在有水流的情况下。琼斯海滩的水流会非常强。
1,000 rescues-- that's way more rescues than David Hasselhoff did on Baywatch . I figure two rescues per episode, 10 years on the air, Roy would still beat him by 560 rescues.
1000次营救——这比《海滩救护队》（Baywatch）里大卫·哈塞尔霍夫（David Hasselhoff）救的人多多了。我想就算每集救两个人，播10年，罗伊还是比他多救了560人。
Which is to say Roy is one of the lifeguardiest lifeguards there is. He had two wins at the national lifeguard competition. He served as an expert lifeguard witness in court cases. And all was well in his happy lifeguarding world until the Speedo mishegoss began in 2007.
也就是说，罗伊是最典型的救生员。他在全国救生员比赛中赢过两次。他曾在法庭上作为救生员专家证人出庭。他那幸福的救生员世界一切都好，直到2007年那场关于三角泳裤的荒唐事开始。
Here's what happened. If you're a lifeguard at Jones Beach, you have to take a physical fitness test every year to prove that you're still able to do the job. It includes a speed test in a pool. You have to swim 100 yards in 1:20, which is actually pretty fast. A lot of these guys train all year for it.
事情是这样的。如果你是琼斯海滩的救生员，每年都必须参加体能测试以证明你仍然能够胜任这份工作。其中包括一项泳池速度测试。你必须在1分20秒内游完100码，这其实相当快。很多救生员全年都在为此训练。
For 15 years, Roy took the swim test in his preferred swimsuit, a pair of jammers. They look like bike shorts without the butt cushion. If you're watching the Olympics right now, all of the male swimmers are wearing them. They're tight, and they go down to just above the knee.
15年来，罗伊都穿着他偏好的泳裤参加测试，那是平角竞速泳裤（jammers）。它们看起来像没有垫片的骑行短裤。如果你现在看奥运会，所有的男性游泳运动员都穿着这种。它们很紧，长度刚好过膝。
But when Roy showed up for the test in 2007, he was told no jammers. His bosses at the Office of Parks and Recreation said, you can only do the test in one of the official Jones Beach lifeguard swimsuits, which means you have three choices-- board shorts, trunks, or Speedo. Board shorts and trunks are loose, so nobody really takes a swim test in them because they create more drag and slow you down. So, in effect, state officials were saying to Roy, you have to take the test in the Speedo.
但当罗伊在2007年参加测试时，他被告知不能穿平角竞速泳裤。他公园娱乐部门的老板说，你只能穿琼斯海滩官方的救生员泳装参加测试，这意味着你有三种选择——沙滩裤、运动短裤或三角泳裤。沙滩裤和运动短裤比较宽松，所以没人真的穿它们参加测试，因为阻力太大，会拖慢速度。所以，实质上州官员是在告诉罗伊，你必须穿三角泳裤参加测试。
Roy said, no way. I won't do it. And he hasn't been a lifeguard at Jones Beach since.
罗伊说，绝不可能。我不会做。从那以后，他就再没当过琼斯海滩的救生员。
It was one of those feelings like, am I making the right decision? I'm throwing away a 40-year career over a principle. It was a difficult decision, a very difficult decision.
那是一种感觉，就像，我做出的决定对吗？我为了一个原则放弃了40年的职业生涯。那是一个艰难的决定，非常艰难的决定。
How long did it take you to decide?
你花了多长时间做决定？
A second.
一秒钟。
I really need to point out he would only have to wear the Speedo for the test, which lasts a minute and 20 seconds. On the job, he'd wear board shorts. Most of the lifeguards do, young and old.
我真的需要指出，他只需要在测试时穿三角泳裤，而测试只持续1分20秒。在工作中，他会穿沙滩裤。大多数救生员，无论老少，都是这么穿的。
Why not just put it on for the test, though?
为什么不为了测试把它穿上呢？
Why didn't Rosa Parks just go to the back of the bus? There were plenty of seats.
为什么罗莎·帕克斯（Rosa Parks）不坐到公交车后座去呢？当时明明有很多空座。
So it's just-- it's the principle of it.
所以这只是——这就是原则问题。
Yeah. Yes.
是的。是的。
The principle, in his mind, was standing up to age discrimination. When I read about all this in The New York Times , I really didn't understand. What's the connection between a Speedo and age discrimination? I've certainly seen older dudes in Speedos.
在他看来，这个原则是反对年龄歧视。当我第一次在《纽约时报》读到这些时，我真的不明白。三角泳裤和年龄歧视之间有什么联系？我当然见过年纪大的人穿三角泳裤。
So I went out and met Roy on a beach not far from his house on Long Island. It was 6:45 in the morning. He was about to go for a mile swim before work.
所以我去了长岛离他家不远的一个海滩见罗伊。当时是早上6点45分。他在上班前正要去游一英里。
So, Roy, can you describe what you're wearing right now?
那么，罗伊，你能描述一下你现在穿的是什么吗？
Well, it's a wet suit. It's a short-sleeve wet suit. And I have my jammers on underneath.
嗯，这是件潜水服。这是件短袖潜水服。我里面穿了平角竞速泳裤。
Roy brought one of his official Jones Beach Speedos to the beach to show me.
罗伊带了一条他官方的琼斯海滩三角泳裤到海滩给我看。
Just describe it for me.
你就给我描述一下吧。
It's an exaggerated thong for lack of a better word.
用一个更好的词来形容的话，它就是一条夸张的丁字裤。
But it's full coverage in the back. So it's not quite a thong, right?
但它后面有完整遮盖。所以还不完全是丁字裤，对吧？
Not quite a thong, right.
不完全是丁字裤，没错。
But to Roy and lots of guys, it might as well be a thong, which is why the Speedo has earned a stable of nicknames-- the weenie bikini, the dingaling sling, the speed don't, the banana hammock, the grape smuggler, the Miami meat tent, the Saint-Tropez truffle duffle, the scrote tote.
但对罗伊和许多人来说，它跟丁字裤没两样，这就是为什么这种三角泳裤赢得了许多绰号——“小弟弟比基尼”、“丁丁吊索”、“速度不要”、“香蕉吊床”、“葡萄偷运者”、“迈阿密肉棚”、“圣特罗佩松露包”、“阴囊托”。
The reason the jammer is preferred by older lifeguards is that you're saying it's more discreet.
年纪较大的救生员更喜欢平角竞速泳裤的原因是，你说它更得体。
Modest.
保守。
More modest?
更保守？
Yes.
是的。
Than the Speedo.
比三角泳裤更保守？
Yes.
是的。
Because it covers your thighs.
因为它们遮住了大腿。
I don't want to get graphic, but your-- the word begins with B. Basically, you're hanging out with the Speedo.
我不想说得太露骨，但你的——那个词以B开头。基本上，穿着三角泳裤你的东西就露在外面。
I get it now, I think.
我想我现在懂了。
And you don't really-- with the jammers, it's not like that.
你真的不会——穿平角竞速泳裤就不会那样。
There's like a little bit more of a roof over your house.
就像你的房子上多了一层屋顶一样。
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
I see.
我明白了。
This is the nut of his argument Roy says once he passed 50, he felt self-conscious in the Speedo. And nobody should have to feel self-conscious to get a job. So Roy refuses to put on the grape smuggler to take the swim test.
这就是他论点的核心，罗伊说一旦过了50岁，他穿三角泳裤就会感到不自在。而没有人应该为了得到一份工作而感到不自在。所以罗伊拒绝穿上那种“葡萄偷运者”来参加游泳测试。
A few weeks later, there's another chance to take the test. He shows up. And this time, he is wearing the official Speedo. He's just got it on over his jammers.
几周后，有另一次参加测试的机会。他现身了。这次他穿了官方的三角泳裤。他只是把它套在平角竞速泳裤外面。
He showed me a video of a conversation he recorded on the pool deck that day. It was a little windy, so the sound isn't great. But he's standing in front of Sue Giuliani who was the director of Jones Beach State Park at the time. And there he is in his jammers plus Speedo outfit, challenging her to turn him away.
他给我看了一段那天在泳池边录下的对话视频。当时有点风，所以声音不太好。但他站在当时的琼斯海滩州立公园主任苏·朱利亚尼（Sue Giuliani）面前。他就那样穿着他的平角裤加三角裤套装，挑战她，不让她拒绝自己。
I've made a compromise.
我做了一个妥协。
That's not going to be acceptable.
那是不被接受的。
You're not going to let me swim like this?
你不让我这样游泳吗？
No.
不。
How come?
为什么？
Because you still have jammers on. So that you cannot wear.
因为你里面还穿着平角竞速泳裤。那是不能穿的。
All right. And is there any reason why they're not allowed?
好吧。有什么理由说明它们是不被允许的吗？
We're not going-- how many times do you want me to repeat it?
我们不打算——你要我重复多少遍？
What?
什么？
You know why they're not allowed.
你知道它们为什么不被允许。
No, no, I don't. I've never been able to--
不，不，我不知道。我从来没能——
I've pretty much--
我已经很——
Joe Scalise, the director of water safety for the state beaches, cuts in.
乔·斯卡利斯（Joe Scalise），州立海滩水上安全主任，插话道。
Are you going to comply or not?
你到底配不配合？
I am complying. I'm wearing my official suit.
我在配合。我穿着我的官方泳裤。
Are you complying with what we want or not?
你到底配不配合我们的要求？
I'm wearing my official suit.
我穿着我的官方泳裤。
So not swimming now?
所以现在不游了是吧？
All right. Let's go.
好吧。我们走。
Did you just go home, then?
那你直接回家了吗？
Basically, I-- well, I stayed around. And I watched everybody take the test.
基本上，我——嗯，我在周围待了一会儿。我看着大家参加测试。
Were there other people taking the test in jammers?
还有其他人穿平角竞速泳裤参加测试吗？
No. No, nobody was allowed to take the test in jammers. So everybody else either put on a Speedo or put on the board shorts, something like that.
没有。没有，没人被允许穿平角竞速泳裤参加测试。所以其他人都要么换上三角泳裤，要么穿上沙滩裤之类的。
Now, Roy said he could have worn board shorts or trunks and still pass the test. He says he could have dungarees and passed. The guy's in ridiculous shape. He does triathlons now, coaches a swim team. In 2012, he had a hip replaced. And seven weeks later, he came in first in his age group in Bermuda's Round the Sound swim race, a 1.2-mile open water swim. He was still using a cane to walk.
现在，罗伊说他本可以穿沙滩裤或者运动短裤也能通过测试。他说就算穿工装裤他也能通过。这家伙的身体素质惊人。他现在参加铁人三项，还教练游泳队。2012年，他换了髋关节。七周后，他在百慕大的“环岛”游泳赛（Round the Sound）中获得了他那个年龄组的第一名，那是一场1.2英里的公开水域游泳比赛。当时他走路还要用拐杖。
So the easy thing for Roy to do would be just take the test in board shorts or Speedo and keep the job he loved. Let bureaucrats be bureaucrats. Just get on with it.
所以罗伊做起来最简单的事就是穿沙滩裤或三角泳裤参加测试，保住他热爱的这份工作。让官僚们去当官僚吧。继续做下去就行了。
That's not Roy. Roy does not back down from a fight. So he sued. He sued the New York State Office of Parks, Recreation and Historic Preservation for $5 million.
罗伊不是那样的人。罗伊从不退缩。所以他起诉了。他起诉了纽约州公园、娱乐和历史保护办公室，索赔500万美元。
Now, the easy thing for the state would have been to just let Jones Beach lifeguards wear jammers. Presumably, if they're good enough for the Olympic swim team, they're good enough for New York's lifeguards. But that's not New York State. It decided to fight.
对州政府来说，简单的事就是让琼斯海滩的救生员穿平角竞速泳裤。大概，如果它们对奥运游泳队来说足够好，对纽约的救生员来说也足够好。但那不是纽约州。它决定应战。
The lawsuit has worked its way through the lower court, which dismissed it, to the appellate court, which ruled in May that it should go to trial. This has been going on for seven years-- seven years. Roy sent me a PDF of his exhibits in the case. It was 1,300 pages long.
诉讼案已经走过了下级法院（已驳回）和上诉法院（今年五月裁定应进行审判）。这已经持续了七年了——整整七年。罗伊寄给我一份他案件中证据的PDF文件。足足有1300页长。
And the thing I really want to know-- because I live in New York and pay taxes in New York-- is why is the state using taxpayer dollars to fight the Speedo suit? This could all been resolved very easily years ago if they just changed the rule, allowed the jammers. Why are Roy and the state fighting each other when they should unite against the real enemy, jellyfish.
我真正想知道的是——因为我住在纽约并在纽约纳税——为什么州政府要用纳税人的钱去打这场三角泳裤官司？如果他们早几年修改规则，允许穿平角竞速泳裤，这一切本来早就轻易解决了。为什么罗伊和州政府要互掐，明明他们应该团结起来对付真正的敌人：水母。
Officials from the state of New York wouldn't talk to me for this story. The Attorney General's office wouldn't talk. Neither would Parks and Rec.
纽约州的官员拒绝就此故事接受我的采访。总检察长办公室拒绝回应。公园娱乐部门也一样。
But they did send me the affidavit of a guy named George Gorman. He oversees all the parks in Long Island. And it lays out their side of the story.
但他们确实发给我一份叫乔治·戈尔曼（George Gorman）的人的宣誓书。他监管长岛所有的公园。里面陈述了他们的立场。
Around 2006, some of the Jones Beach lifeguards started taking the test in full-body swimsuits. Management became concerned that those guys were only passing because they were wearing the full-body swimsuits. So they decided to change the rules.
2006年左右，一些琼斯海滩的救生员开始穿着全身式泳衣参加测试。管理层开始担心那些家伙能通过仅仅是因为穿了全身式泳衣。所以他们决定更改规则。
Starting in 2007, lifeguards could only take the test in one of the three official Jones Beach uniform swimsuits. No more full body suits, and also no jammers because jammers aren't part of the uniform. In his deposition, George Gorman said, quote, "we determined it was best that the lifeguards wear the uniforms that they're assigned to wear while they're on duty."
从2007年开始，救生员只能穿琼斯海滩三种官方制服泳裤中的一种参加测试。禁止全身式泳衣，也不允许平角竞速泳裤，因为平角竞速泳裤不是制服的一部分。在证词中，乔治·戈尔曼说：“我们决定救生员最好穿上他们值班时被要求穿的制服。”
Seems reasonable, right? Not if you're Roy. He points out, if jammers really are significantly faster, wouldn't you want your lifeguards to wear a faster suit? Get them out to drowning victims sooner?
看起来很合理，对吧？如果你是罗伊就不这么看了。他指出，如果平角竞速泳裤真的显著更快，难道你不希望救生员穿更快的泳裤吗？让他们更快地到达溺水者身边？
And as it happens, New York Parks and Rec allows lifeguards to take their qualifying test in jammers in the rest of the state.
而且碰巧的是，纽约州公园娱乐部允许救生员在州内其他地方穿平角竞速泳裤参加资格测试。
Upstate. I went upstate to take the test. And I wore my jammers.
州北部。我去了州北部参加测试。我穿了我的平角竞速泳裤。
You took the test upstate?
你在州北部参加了测试？
Yes. And I wore my jammers. And people wore the jammers. And I have pictures of that. And it's part of the exhibit, of guys taking the test in their jammers.
是的。我穿了我的平角竞速泳裤。人们也都穿。我有那里的照片。作为证据的一部分，显示那些人在穿平角竞速泳裤参加测试。
Upstate?
州北部？
Yes. The same employer. New York State Department of Recreation, the same employer, allows the jammers.
是的。同一个雇主。纽约州娱乐部，同一个雇主，允许穿平角竞速泳裤。
So your theory about this is that they are targeting Long Island because why?
所以你认为他们针对长岛是因为什么？
Because 90% of the older, the over-50 lifeguards work on Long Island. It's the biggest group of older lifeguards anywhere.
因为90%的老年人，50岁以上的救生员都在长岛工作。那是任何地方最大的老年救生员群体。
For what it's worth, the state told me that the rules are different on Long Island because it's a more strenuous job lifeguarding on the ocean-- upstate it's all lakes and pools.
不管怎么说，州政府告诉我规则在长岛不同，因为在海洋做救生员更费力——州北部都是湖泊和泳池。
Why do you think it is that they don't want older lifeguards?
你认为他们为什么不想留住老救生员？
Well, I think they don't like the fact that older lifeguards have influence over the younger guys. And when you're a member of management, you don't want anybody having influence over your employees except you. And when you have to deal with the union, and you have to deal with the offices of the unions who are all older guys, and they know the beach, you don't want that.
嗯，我认为他们不喜欢老年救生员对年轻队员有影响力。当你属于管理层时，你不希望除了你之外有任何人对你的员工有影响力。当你必须处理工会事务，处理那些都是老家伙的工会办公室时，他们了解海滩，你就不想要那样了。
Yep, there's a lifeguard union. Roy was the president of the union for years. And at that point in 2007, when he refused to wear the Speedo, he was the union's chief negotiator. When Sue Giuliani tells him to follow the rules--
没错，确实有个救生员工会。罗伊做了很多年工会主席。而在2007年他拒绝穿三角泳裤时，他是工会的首席谈判代表。当苏·朱利亚尼告诉他遵守规则时——
So that you cannot wear.
那是不能穿的。
--she knows him. He's the guy the union sends to argue its side. And these guys telling him he can't wear his jammers? They're management. This is a scantily clad labor dispute.
——她认识他。他是工会派出来辩论的一方。而这些家伙告诉他不能穿平角竞速泳裤？他们是管理层。这是一场衣不蔽体的劳资纠纷。
I asked some other older lifeguards about this. And three out of the four of them agreed. This is about the union, which actually has a history of fighting age discrimination. In 1966, they went on strike because the state tried to impose an age limit of 35 for Jones Beach lifeguards. So they walked off the beach. A week later, the state caved.
我问了一些其他老年救生员这件事。四个人中有三个表示同意。这是关于工会的问题，它其实有对抗年龄歧视的历史。1966年，他们举行了罢工，因为州政府试图将琼斯海滩救生员的年龄限制定为35岁。于是他们撤离了海滩。一周后，州政府屈服了。
Knowing this-- that the suits and the swimsuits have a history with each other-- that helped me understand what Roy's fight was really about. Roy told me one reason he took a stand was that management was supposed to tell the union if they wanted to change a rule like this. And this time, they didn't.
知道这些——诉讼和泳衣之间的历史纠葛——帮我理解了罗伊的斗争究竟是为了什么。罗伊告诉我，他站出来的一个原因是，如果管理层想要更改这样的规则，本应该通知工会。而这一次，他们没有。
Roy's got a weekend job now at a private beach club. But it's not the same.
罗伊现在在一个私人海滩俱乐部有一份周末工作。但感觉不一样了。
I like where I'm working now. I really do. But you get one rescue a year if you're lucky. And then it's what's called a puddle jumper.
我喜欢我现在的工作。真的。但如果你运气好，一年也就救一个人。而且那通常被称为“水坑跳跃者”（puddle jumper）。
What is a puddle jumper?
什么是“水坑跳跃者”？
A puddle jumper is where you really don't even need to get your head wet. And at Jones Beach in the old days, we would have these tremendous rescues, just these great rescues.
“水坑跳跃者”就是那种你连头都不用弄湿。而在琼斯海滩的过去，我们会进行惊天动地的救援，就是那种伟大的救援。
His friends from Jones Beach tease him that he's in exile now.
他在琼斯海滩的朋友嘲笑他是被流放了。
How often do you go visit them?
你多久回去看望他们一次？
Not that often. I keep in touch with them constantly, but I don't go down there that often. To be honest, it does hurt. It hurts to go down there. That was my beach. It was my home for so many years.
没那么频繁。我一直和他们保持联系，但我没那么常去那里。老实说，确实很痛。去那里会痛。那是我的海滩。它曾是我多年的家。
If Roy's theory is true, then the state is trying to get rid of the older lifeguards on Long Island by forcing them into Speedos. But if that's true, as far as I can tell, the only lifeguard they've managed to get rid of is Roy.
如果罗伊的理论是真的，那么州政府正试图通过强迫他们穿三角泳裤来赶走长岛的老救生员。但如果这是真的，据我所知，他们成功赶走的唯一救生员只有罗伊。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "SPEEDO" BY THE CADILLACS]
[音乐——《Speedo》，The Cadillacs演唱]
Act Two, Say Yes to Summer. So I just finished making a movie with Mike Birbiglia, who is on our show sometimes. And the movie's about improv comedians. And I thought that it would be fun to invite some here on the show to do stuff about summer.
第二幕，答应夏天。我刚和有时会来我们节目的迈克·比尔比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）拍完一部电影。那部电影关于即兴喜剧演员。我想邀请一些人来节目里做关于夏天的事情应该会很有趣。
And we got some great ones-- John Lutz, Tami Sagher, Connor Ratliff, Gary Richardson, Kate Micucci, Shannon O'Neill, who's the artistic director of improv theater The Upright Citizens Brigade Theater. Mike Birbiglia came, too.
我们请到了一些很棒的人——约翰·卢茨（John Lutz）、塔米·萨格（Tami Sagher）、康纳·拉特利夫（Connor Ratliff）、加里·理查森（Gary Richardson）、凯特·米库奇（Kate Micucci）、香农·奥尼尔（Shannon O'Neill），她是即兴剧团“正直公民大队剧院”（The Upright Citizens Brigade Theater）的艺术总监。迈克·比尔比利亚也来了。
And they did this show at The Upright Citizens Brigade theater in New York. And they did it in this style of improv where the way it works is that somebody tells a true story on stage. And then the performers make up scenes based on things in that real story. And then somebody else tells another true story which kicks off more improvised scenes, and so on.
他们在纽约的“正直公民大队剧院”表演了这个节目。他们用的是即兴表演风格，这种风格的运作方式是：有人在台上讲一个真实故事。然后表演者根据那个真实故事里的情节编造出场景。接着另一个人讲另一个真实故事，从而引发更多即兴场景，如此循环。
And so, if you just want to picture this, the cast and I are on stage. There's an audience. And we started this show with a true story that I told.
所以，如果你能想象一下，我和剧组成员在台上。台下有观众。我们以我讲的一个真实故事开始了表演。
So when I was 13, my parents had enough money to take us on one of our very first family vacations. And we went to Florida. And one of the things that made this possible was we got a deal on the hotel.
我13岁那年，父母攒够了钱带我们去进行了第一次家庭度假。我们去了佛罗里达。让这一切成为可能的原因之一是我们拿到了一份酒店优惠。
My dad was an accountant. I grew up in Baltimore. And we got the deal because my dad was the accountant for the Baltimore branch franchise of the Playboy Club.
我父亲是个会计。我在巴尔的摩长大。我们拿到优惠是因为我父亲是巴尔的摩分部花花公子俱乐部（Playboy Club）的会计。
And I would just say now it's sort of hard to remember, if you're under 40, I think, there was a point where Playboy was cool. It's sort of unimaginable now. But if you imagine you couldn't get porn on your phone.
我得说现在很难记住，如果你不到40岁，我觉得，曾经有一段时间花花公子（Playboy）是很酷的。现在简直难以想象。但如果你想象一下你手机上没法看色情内容。
And so we were going to go down. Playboy owned hotels. And they had a hotel in Miami called the Playboy Plaza. So we were going to be at this hotel that seemed very glamorous. There were going to be Playboy bunnies at the hotel serving drinks at the bar and at the pool. I was a 13-year-old boy. This was incredible.
所以我们要去那里。花花公子拥有酒店。他们在迈阿密有一家酒店叫花花公子广场（Playboy Plaza）。所以我们要去住那家看起来非常迷人的酒店。会有花花公子兔女郎在酒店酒吧和泳池边服务。我是一个13岁的男孩。这太不可思议了。
We were going to fly in an airplane. It was one of the very first times I ever did that-- also incredible. There would be the ocean, which being from Baltimore, we called (IN BALTIMORE ACCENT) the ocean. And so this had all the makings of a great vacation.
我们要坐飞机去。那是我第一次坐飞机——也太不可思议了。会有海洋，因为来自巴尔的摩，我们称之为（用巴尔的摩口音）“海洋”。所以这具备了一次伟大度假的所有要素。
And then when we got to the hotel, it was everything we wanted. And in addition, The Jackson 5 was staying there. August of 1972, Michael Jackson and I are the same age. We were both 13.
当我们到达酒店时，它就是我们想要的一切。此外，杰克逊五人组（The Jackson 5）也住在那里。1972年8月，迈克尔·杰克逊和我同龄。我们都13岁。
And so you would see The Jackson 5 come out of the elevator for dinner, dressed all in completely matching gold suede suits with fringe. And you would see them at the pool just like playing in the pool like other kids, which was us.
所以你会看到杰克逊五人组穿着完全配套的金黄色麂皮绒西装，上面带着流苏，从电梯里出来去吃晚餐。你会看到他们像其他孩子一样在泳池里玩耍，也就是我们。
And I should say, I remember goofing around in the pool with the youngest one, who was seven years old-- a girl-- because she seemed like the most approachable. I knew she wasn't actually famous. Later, of course, I learned she is Janet Jackson. I played Marco Polo with Janet Jackson.
我还应该说，我记得在泳池里和最小的那个孩子玩闹，她当时七岁——是个女孩——因为她看起来最平易近人。我当时不知道她其实很有名。后来，当然，我了解到她是珍妮·杰克逊（Janet Jackson）。我和珍妮·杰克逊玩过马可波罗（Marco Polo）游戏。
And I have brought with me a photo of me and Michael Jackson from that vacation. I have it here. Now before I show this to you, I want to just-- I need to preface with some context, which is that while the Jacksons were becoming international superstars, I myself was working in the entertainment business. I had gone to the Baltimore County Public Library and taken out some books on how to do magic tricks. And I was doing birthday parties all over Baltimore County for fees as high as $10-- also animal balloonery.
我带了一张那次度假我和迈克尔·杰克逊的照片。我带在这儿。现在在我给你们看之前，我需要——我得先加上一些背景，那就是当杰克逊一家正在成为国际巨星时，我自己也在娱乐行业工作。我去过巴尔的摩县图书馆，借了一些关于如何变魔术的书。我当时在巴尔的摩县到处做生日派对，收费高达10美元——还有做气球动物。
And so here is the photo. And the audience here can see that my back is to the camera. What I'm doing-- you can't see my hands. I'm doing the disappearing coin trick. And the expression on Michael Jackson's face? He is literally rolling his eyes.
所以这就是那张照片。这里的观众可以看到我的背对着相机。我在做什么——你们看不到我的手。我在表演硬币消失魔术。而迈克尔·杰克逊脸上的表情？他简直在翻白眼。
So just to explain to the radio audience, the cast is sitting on stools with microphones. And so you guys heard the opening story. It's on you.
为了给广播听众解释一下，演员们坐在高脚凳上拿着麦克风。所以你们听到了开场故事。轮到你们了。
Marco.
马可。
Polo.
波罗。
Marco.
马可。
(SINGING) Polo.
（唱歌）波罗。
Marco.
马可。
Polo.
波罗。
(SINGING) Polo.
（唱歌）波罗。
Marco.
马可。
You really don't know where we are?
你真的不知道我们在哪吗？
I love The Jackson 5.
我爱杰克逊五人组。
Well, what do you say, guys? Should we give them a show?
嗯，你们怎么说，伙计们？我们要给他们表演一个节目吗？
We have been workshopping a pool song.
我们一直在排练一首泳池歌。
Hey, you're not going to sing the pool song without Tito.
嘿，没有铁托（Tito），你们可不能唱泳池歌。
Hey, guys. I heard we're singing the new pool song.
嘿，伙计们。听说我们要唱新泳池歌了。
Uh, Michael, no one wants you here.
额，迈克尔，没人想让你来这里。
Hold on. Let me put on my swimming gloves. Oh, no. I lost one. So are we going to sing this pool song or what?
等一下。让我戴上我的游泳手套。哦，不。我丢了一只。所以我们要唱这首泳池歌了吗？
Well, I've got my bass guitar right here. I'm could walk us on in with a--
嗯，我这儿有我的低音吉他。我可以带我们入场——
[SCAT SINGING]
[斯卡唱法]
(SINGING) Dip that toe in the water. Dip that toe in the water.
（唱歌）脚尖入水。脚尖入水。
(SINGING) I'm sliding down the slide. I'm sliding down the slide, splishy splash. Sliding down the slide. Sliding down the slide. Come on, everybody.
（唱歌）我正从滑梯滑下。我正从滑梯滑下，扑通一声。从滑梯滑下。从滑梯滑下。来吧，大家。
(SINGING) Welcome The Jackson 5 to your local hotel pool. Welcome us, the five of us. You can take this tale to school.
（唱歌）欢迎杰克逊五人组来到你当地的酒店泳池。欢迎我们，我们五个。你可以把这事当笑谈讲。
(SINGING) Sliding down the slide. Sliding down the slide.
（唱歌）从滑梯滑下。从滑梯滑下。
Again, we're workshopping it.
再说一次，我们在排练。
End scene.
场景结束。
Excuse me.
打扰一下。
Yes? How can I help you?
是的？有什么能帮您的吗？
Yes, I'm here with my son. Perhaps you recognize him from birthday parties across Bernard County.
是的，我和我儿子在这。也许您从伯纳德县各处的生日派对上认出他来？
I'm-- OK. I don't recognize him from that, but--
我——好吧。我没从那儿认出他，但是——
Joshy, introduce yourself.
乔希（Joshy），做个自我介绍。
Hello. My name is Joshy the Magnificent.
你好。我的名字是“伟大的乔希”。
And we've been waiting in this corner booth for five minutes. And no one has come to wait on us.
我们在那个角落包厢等了五分钟了。没人来服务我们。
Oh, I'm very sorry about that. I can take your order right now if you want. How about some drinks?
哦，对此我深表歉意。如果您愿意，我现在就可以为您点餐。来点饮料怎么样？
How can we order when the menus have disappeared?
当菜单都消失了，我们要怎么点餐？
Ta-da!
变！
I'm going to get you guys some water. And I'll be back with some menus.
我去给你们弄点水。我马上带菜单回来。
Joshy will have a glass of sour milk, please.
乔希要一杯酸牛奶，谢谢。
All right. All right. I'll be right back.
好的。好的。我马上回来。
Joshy.
乔希。
I love you, Mommy.
我爱你，妈妈。
I love you so much. So much.
我也爱你，非常非常多。
So much.
非常多。
End scene.
场景结束。
I think what's special about summer when you're a kid is that it doesn't even feel like the rest of your life. Like, you feel like there's life, and then there's summer. And then when you get older-- I'm embarrassed to admit this-- I'm barely aware that it's summer. And I'm like, OK, it's summer. Like, I'll just--
我觉得小孩子时夏天最特别的是，它甚至感觉不像你生活的其余部分。就像，你觉得有平时的生活，然后有夏天。当你长大后——承认这点我很尴尬——我几乎没意识到是夏天。我只会，好吧，夏天到了。就像，我只是——
I'll have that thing, too, when it starts getting hot where it's like, ugh, it's getting a little hot. I never had that as a kid. You'd be excited when it's hot because--
当天气开始变热时，我也会有那种感觉，比如，呃，有点热了。我小时候从没那样过。天气热你会很兴奋，因为——
I don't know as a kid, so often the family reunions were in hot ass Pensacola, Florida, like unbelievably hot and populated with 100% old people. So nobody was out-- it wasn't even like kids were out playing.
我不知道，小时候，家庭聚会经常在热死人的佛罗里达州彭萨科拉，不可思议地热，而且住着100%的老年人。所以没人出来——甚至连孩子们都没出来玩。
So I was acutely aware of how hot it was because I would get outside and just stand there. It would be me and my cousins just standing, looking around, hoping for something to inspire us to play. Like, these old people didn't have balls or anything to do, so we would just walk to get a juice and drink the whole juice on the way back home because we were dying. Ugh, Pensacola sucks. I hate-- I hate Pensacola, Florida.
所以我敏锐地意识到天有多热，因为我会走到外面站着。我和我的堂兄弟们只是站着，四处张望，希望能有灵感激励我们去玩。那些老家伙没有球或任何事可做，所以我们只会走去买果汁，在回家的路上就把整杯果汁喝光，因为我们快渴死了。呃，彭萨科拉糟透了。我讨厌——我讨厌佛罗里达的彭萨科拉。
Jane! Jane, come to the window.
简！简，快到窗边来。
What?
什么？
There's a bunch of children just standing.
有一群孩子在那站着。
We want your balls. Give us your toys.
我们要你们的球。把玩具给我们。
That one sounded a little bit like John Lennon. What is this?
那个听起来有点像约翰·列侬（John Lennon）。这是什么？
You're right. You're right. Jane, you're right.
你说得对。你说得对。简，你说得对。
Toys.
玩具。
That was unmistakably a Liverpool accent.
那绝对是利物浦口音。
I'm John Lennon. I'm visiting with these children.
我是约翰·列侬。我正在探访这些孩子。
Jane! What do we do, Jane?
简！我们该怎么办，简？
Do we adopt them? I don't know, Carl.
我们收养他们吗？我不知道，卡尔。
We can't adopt a full-grown Brit.
我们不能收养一个成年英国人。
Who says we can't?
谁说我们不能？
So class, we've got a new sixth grader who has just moved to town. So, John, why don't you tell the class a little bit about yourself?
所以同学们，我们有个新来的六年级学生刚搬到镇上。那么，约翰，为什么不向班级介绍一下你自己呢？
I'm from Liverpool.
我来自利物浦。
All right, John. Why don't you have a seat over there by Shelley? And--
好吧，约翰。为什么不去谢莉（Shelley）旁边坐下呢？然后——
Yeah, sit next to me.
是啊，坐我旁边。
Oh, you don't seem to be fitting in that desk.
哦，你好像坐不进那个课桌。
I'm a full-grown man.
我是个成年男人。
All right. Well, Terry, you were in the middle of your talk about what you did this summer.
好吧。那么，泰瑞（Terry），你刚才在讲你暑假做了什么，请继续。
Yes, this summer I went on a cruise to the Bahamas-- me, my mom, my dad, my younger brother Jason. We got on the cruise. And there was 100 bedrooms. 100 bedrooms. And in the morning, you get up and everybody has breakfast together. And sometimes there's different entertainers in the middle of the day. If you don't want to go to the entertainer, you can go swim or you can go lay on the deck.
是的，今年夏天我去了巴哈马群岛游轮——我和我妈妈、爸爸，还有我弟弟杰森（Jason）。我们上了游轮。有100间卧室。100间卧室。早上起来大家一起吃早餐。中午有时会有不同的艺人。如果你不想看艺人，你可以去游泳或躺在甲板上。
And once we port-- that's what they call it when the boat stops in the city-- once you port, you and your family get together. Make sure you have your passport. Because if you don't, they might not let you back on the boat, no matter what. We do all this. Then we, uh-- oo, one time, my brother stepped on a jellyfish.
一旦我们靠港——那是当船停在城市时的叫法——一旦靠港，你和你的家人就聚在一起。确保你有护照。因为如果没有，他们可能就不会让你回船上了，不管怎样都不行。我们做了这一切。然后我们，呃——哦，有一次，我弟弟踩到了一只水母。
I have a story. I'm the biggest pop star in all the world.
我有个故事。我是全世界最大的流行歌星。
John, just one second, please. Terry is telling a very interesting story.
约翰，等一秒钟，好吗。泰瑞正在讲一个非常有意思的故事。
I made the biggest hits in all of America and also in Britain.
我创造了全美乃至英国最大的金曲。
Shh.
嘘。
Oh, do you want me to tell you what happens when you get back on the boat?
哦，你们想听听回船上后会发生什么吗？
Yeah.
想。
OK, you get back on the boat. And you go upstairs. And you have dinner. And the dinner can either be pork, or it can be chicken, or it can be just vegetables because some people don't even like meat stuff. They just want to eat vegetables. Can you believe it?
好的，你回到船上。然后你上楼。然后吃晚餐。晚餐可以是猪肉，可以是鸡肉，也可以只是蔬菜，因为有些人甚至不喜欢肉食。他们只想吃蔬菜。你们能相信吗？
Tell us about the toilets on the boat.
告诉我们船上的厕所。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
This is a rubbish.
这简直是垃圾。
Scene.
场景。
I stole once over a summer. I was 10 years old, I believe. And I was on a cruise, actually, in Cancun, Mexico. I was playing with some keychain that had a basketball on it because I was a huge basketball guy back then. I'm still a big basketball guy. I love the sport.
我夏天的时候偷过一次东西。我想我当时10岁。我其实当时在墨西哥坎昆游轮上。我在玩一个上面有个篮球的钥匙链，因为我那时是个超级篮球迷。我现在还是个大篮球迷。我热爱这项运动。
So I'm spinning it around on my finger. And we leave the store. And maybe 20 minutes later, I realize I've still got it. And I'm freaking out because this was a summer that when I was younger, I did taekwondo. And one year, I went to state and placed at state, was supposed to go to regionals-- oh no, not regionals. I went to state, then regionals. I was supposed to go to the national tournament in Las Vegas, Nevada. But I passed to go on this cruise.
所以我把它在手指上转啊转。然后我们离开了商店。大约20分钟后，我意识到我还在拿着它。我吓坏了，因为这是个夏天，我当时很小的时候练过跆拳道。有一年，我参加了州赛并拿到名次，本应该去参加地区赛——哦不，不是地区赛。我去了州赛，然后地区赛。我本应该去内华达州拉斯维加斯参加全国锦标赛。但我为了这趟游轮放弃了。
And I found out that had I gone to Las Vegas, I would have been one of four people in my age and weight division. And I would have automatically been going to represent the United States of America in Korea. And I passed on that cruise around the Gulf of Mexico.
我发现如果我去了拉斯维加斯，我将是同年龄和体重级别中四个人之一。并且我将自动代表美利坚合众国去韩国。但我为了墨西哥湾周围的那趟游轮放弃了。
Wait, wait wait. Are you bringing up the theft because you thought it was causal? Like the fact that you did this bad thing led to you not going to Korea?
等等，等等。你提起盗窃是因为你认为它是因果相关的吗？就像你做了坏事导致你没能去韩国？
No. I thought that I can't believe that instead of being in Korea, I'm here stealing. I was freaking out because I saw two very different paths in my life. And I had chose the wrong one. I had picked the wrong path.
不。我只是想，我不相信我本应该在韩国，但我却在这里偷东西。我吓坏了，因为我看到了人生中两条截然不同的路。而我选择了错误的那条。我选错了路。
Sam, you don't want to go on the class trip?
山姆（Sam），你不想参加班级旅行吗？
No, because I have a chance to go on this cruise. And it just sounds like way more fun. So have a good time on-- the trip sounds fun for some other people.
不，因为我有机会参加这趟游轮。这听起来好玩多了。所以祝你们玩得愉快——旅行对某些人来说听起来很有趣。
I didn't want to mention this to the rest of the class, Sam--
山姆，我不想向班里其他人提这件事——
Yeah--
是啊——
Then why am I still here? I'm leaving. No one ever tells me anything.
那我为什么还在这儿？我要走了。没人告诉过我任何事。
You do not move. You are in punishment. That is why you are still here.
你哪里也不准动。你在受罚。这就是你还在这儿的原因。
OK.
好的。
Maybe, Cooper, instead of asking me why you are still here, you should ask yourself why you're still here.
也许，库珀（Cooper），与其问我你为什么还在这儿，不如问问你自己为什么还在这儿。
Cooper, why am I still here? Cause I'm cool.
库珀，我为什么还在这儿？因为我很酷。
Wrong answer, Cooper, wrong answer. So, Sam, honey--
回答错误，库珀，回答错误。那么，山姆，亲爱的——
Should I go on a trip? I mean, I feel like I don't think I'll be missing out.
我应该去旅行吗？我的意思是，我觉得我不觉得我会错过什么。
Sam OK, I didn't tell the rest of the class this.
山姆，好吧，我没告诉班里其他人这个。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And I know the permission slip says we're just going to Great America to do physics calculations.
我知道准假条上写着我们只是去美国乐园（Great America）做物理计算。
Yeah.
是啊。
But when we get there, there's a physics bowl that's going to happen.
但当我们到了那儿，会有一个物理碗比赛。
That's it?
就这些？
No, Cooper, that's not it.
不，库珀，不止这些。
OK, because that was kind of lame. Hey, why are you here, Cooper? Because you're the best, man. Give me five! I can't because I'm me.
好的，因为那听起来有点逊。嘿，你为什么在这儿，库珀？因为我是最棒的，伙计。击个掌！我不行因为我是我。
But I mean, I could go to the beach and be on the ocean.
但我的意思是，我可以去海滩然后在海洋里。
That sounds way better.
那听起来好多了。
But I mean, if you really need--
但如果你们真的需要——
Cooper likes your idea, huh? Do you want to be like a Cooper?
库珀喜欢你的主意，是吧？你想成为像库珀那样的人吗？
Well, not really because he picks his nose a lot but--
嗯，不太想，因为他经常挖鼻子，但是——
That's 'cause it's tasty!
那是因为那玩意儿很美味！
Scene.
场景。
I feel like there's something about summer when you're a kid where I have all these memories as a teenager where we'd walk around town late at night when we were probably like 13, 14 years old. And we wouldn't have a plan. But we had nowhere to be.
我觉得小时候的夏天有些特别之处，我有所有关于十几岁时的回忆，我们可能在13、14岁的时候深夜在镇上走来走去。我们没有计划。但我们哪里都不用去。
So we'd walk to one of our friend's houses. Then we'd walk to the White Hen Pantry. And we'd order sandwiches. And we'd just sit there on the corner. And we were like, this is pretty cool.
所以我们会走到某个朋友家。然后走到White Hen Pantry便利店。我们会点三明治。我们就坐在街角。我们当时觉得，这挺酷的。
Hey, listen, I know we don't normally plan this out, but I went ahead and made an itinerary. Here's yours.
嘿，听着，我知道我们通常不会计划这些，但我已经做好了行程。这是你的。
OK.
好的。
Got enough for everybody. So, I mean, like right now, it says we meet up, pass out itineraries.
每个人都有。所以，我的意思是，像现在这样，上面写着我们见面，分发行程表。
Yeah, I feel like that that was an unnecessary step because--
是啊，我觉得那是不必要的步骤，因为——
Now I can check it off.
现在我可以把它勾掉了。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Kind of takes away the fun right? Isn't that what--
有点破坏乐趣，对吧？那不是——
Hey, Connor, I got this. It said I should show up at 7:52 and just reject you guys?
嘿，康纳（Connor），我拿到了。上面说我应该在7点52分出现并拒绝你们？
Yeah.
是的。
Hey, Samantha.
嘿，萨曼莎（Samantha）。
Hi, Samantha.
嗨，萨曼莎。
Hey, Samantha.
嘿，萨曼莎。
Don't do that again.
别再那样做了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交错的声音]
I mean, it's working. Yeah, it's working. I mean, that was--
我的意思是，它管用。是啊，它管用。我的意思是，那是个——
It's right on time. I think it didn't hurt as much because there was an inevitability to it that--
时间刚刚好。我觉得它没那么伤人，因为有一种必然性，那——
Scene.
场景。
I was always really bad at getting or finding summer jobs that weren't terrible. And--
我总是很不擅长寻找那些不糟糕的暑期工作。而且——
You're bad at finding real-life jobs that aren't terrible.
你不擅长寻找现实中不糟糕的工作。
Thanks, Tami. I'll have you know I'm going be dressed as a pretzel all next week.
谢谢，塔米（Tami）。我要让你知道，下周整整一周我都要打扮成一个椒盐卷饼。
Is that real?
那是真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Not a joke.
不是开玩笑。
In what context?
在什么背景下？
Honestly, I've said too much already.
老实说，我已经说得够多了。
You can tell us, but you guys just can't tell anybody. Why will you be dressed like a pretzel next week?
你可以告诉我们，但你们不能告诉任何人。为什么你下周要打扮成椒盐卷饼？
Nobody tweet this.
没人要发推特说这个。
National branded snack mix, internet only, ad content.
全国品牌零食混合装，纯网络广告内容。
Standing ovation.
起立鼓掌。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't think anybody could fit that in a tweet.
我不觉得有人能把那塞进一条推特里。
I think my favorite part is that you thought by saying it that we could ruin it.
我觉得我最喜欢的部分是，你以为你说出来我们就能把它搞砸。
Yeah.
是啊。
We can't make it worse.
我们没法让它更糟了。
All right. So anyway, one summer there was this local sandwich shop in my hometown. And the guy who owned the sandwich shop, he also owned these fireworks stands that would go up near the highway. And they needed someone to guard the fireworks stand at night.
好的。总之，有一个夏天，我家乡有一家当地的三明治店。拥有这家店的家伙，还拥有公路附近的一些烟花摊。他们需要有人在晚上看守烟花摊。
And I heard about this job opportunity. And so I said, are you looking for someone? And he said, yeah, are you willing to do it? And I said, what do I need to do? And I was going to make $500 for the night. I would show up at 9:00 or 10:00 at night or something, whenever they were closing. And then I would just sit in the tent all night until morning.
我听说了这个工作机会。所以我问，你们在找人吗？他说，是啊，你愿意做吗？我说，我需要做什么？我可以那一晚赚500美元。我会在晚上9点或10点左右到，或者什么时候他们关门。然后我就一直坐在帐篷里直到早上。
Wait, $500?
等等，500美元？
That's so much money?
那有很多钱？
For one night?
就一晚？
Yeah. It was $400 or $500.
是啊。是400或500美元。
That's significantly more than you're making to be a pretzel.
那比你做椒盐卷饼赚的钱多得多。
That's not true, actually.
那其实不是真的。
Wait.
等等。
I wouldn't be--
我不会——
Wait, Collin, you realize that was, for sure, guns or drugs.
等等，科林（Collin），你意识到那肯定和枪支或毒品有关。
I don't know. All I know is I made up big plans. I had a black-and-white portable television I brought with myself. I'll just watch TV all night and read.
我不知道。我只知道我制定了宏伟计划。我带了一台黑白便携电视机。我会整晚看电视和读书。
And so I showed up. And there were a bunch of people already there. And I said, hi, I'm supposed to guard the fireworks stand. And they said, no, you're not. And I said, what? And they were like, we're doing it.
所以我去了。那里已经有一群人在那儿了。我说，嗨，我是来守烟花摊的。他们说，不，你不是。我说，什么？他们说，我们在守。
And I was like, I was told I was hired to do this job. And it was supposed to be $500 for the night. And they're like, oh, there was a mix-up. And I was like, oh. And so they said come back next week and you can do next week. So I thought, oh, OK, well, that's good.
我当时说，我被告知我被雇来做这份工作。应该那一晚是500美元。他们说，哦，搞错了。我当时说，哦。所以他们说下周再来，你下周做。所以我想，哦，好吧，那挺好。
And so the next week I went to the fireworks stand on Saturday night to guard it. And the same bunch of guys were there. And they're like, nah, it was a mix-up. I think they just lied to me as a trick, just to see this teenager show up and just tell him to go away.
所以下周六晚上我去了烟花摊看守。同样那群家伙也在那儿。他们说，不，搞错了。我觉得他们只是在撒谎骗我，只是为了看到这个青少年出现并让他走开。
So what you're going to do is you're going to guard this area right here.
所以你要做的是，你要看守这片区域。
OK, yeah.
好的，是。
This is the beach.
这是海滩。
Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Cool. So just get here--
当然。是啊，是啊，是啊。酷。所以就在——
You're just going to guard the beach. If anyone walks down the beach, you're just going to give them the business.
你只是要看守海滩。如果有人走在海滩上，你就给他们点颜色看看。
OK. Yeah, I can do that. Be here at sundown? Hang out all night?
好的。是啊，我能做到。日落时到这儿？在那待整晚？
You get here at sundown. You stay here all night.
你日落时到这儿。你整晚待在这里。
Cool. Yeah.
酷。是啊。
And if anything goes down--
如果发生什么事——
And you're giving me $12,000?
你要给我12000美元？
That's right.
没错。
OK.
好的。
That's right.
没错。
Cool. Cool.
酷。酷。
I will cut you a cashier's check in the morning.
我早上会给你开一张出纳支票。
Awesome. Yeah, awesome.
太棒了。是啊，太棒了。
6:00 AM, I will be here with a cashier's check--
早上6点，我会拿着出纳支票在这里——
Awesome.
太棒了。
--for $12,000.
——12000美元。
Great. Great. That sounds awesome.
太好了。太好了。听起来太棒了。
Cut to sunset.
切到日落。
Yeah, I'm here to watch the beach.
是啊，我在这儿守海滩。
No, you're not.
不，你不是。
Yes. Yes, I am.
是啊。是啊，我是。
Oh, no, man. I'm watching the beach tonight, baby.
哦，不，伙计。今晚我守海滩，宝贝。
OK, well, I was told that this dude who makes milkshakes at the sandwich shop I go to--
好的，好吧，我被告知那个我在三明治店买奶昔的家伙——
Yeah, Milky Joe?
是啊，奶昔乔（Milky Joe）？
Yeah, yeah, Milky Joe.
是啊，是啊，奶昔乔。
Yeah, a mix-up with Milky Joe. Milky Joe told me I'm watching the beach tonight.
是啊，奶昔乔搞错了。奶昔乔告诉我今晚我守海滩。
Gotcha. Milky Joe brought me here this afternoon.
懂了。奶昔乔今天下午把我带到这儿的。
Yeah, that was later than what happened with me on the other time that it did. So it was all fixed. It was so crazy. It was the other side of the time that you did it.
是啊，那比我上次发生的情况要晚。所以一切都解决了。这太疯狂了。那和你做的时候是同一时间。
Oh, OK. Cool. Cool, cool.
哦，好的。酷。酷，酷，酷。
Cut to the next day. An office. There's a window out to the ocean.
切到第二天。办公室。有个窗户对着海洋。
And there's a picture right here that says "we own the beach."
那里有张画写着“海滩属于我们”。
Hey, I want you to come look out this window, will you?
嘿，我要你来看看这扇窗户，行吗？
All right.
好的。
So you see water there?
你看那儿有水吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
You know what I'm not seeing? Any beach.
你知道我没看到什么吗？任何海滩。
Well, maybe someone--
嗯，也许有人——
I specifically told you to get someone to guard the beach last night--
我明确告诉你让人昨晚守海滩——
I hired--
我雇了——
--so that something like this wouldn't happen.
——这样就不会发生这种事了。
I hired two guys. I hired two guys to watch the beach.
我雇了两个人。我雇了两个人看守海滩。
Did you tell them that they were to work together?
你告诉他们要一起工作了吗？
No. Well, I hired them in opposition to one another.
没有。嗯，我雇他们时让他们互相竞争。
Like, I don't know how they hire security guards where you come from, but where I come from you pay somebody $12,000, they watch the beach.
我的意思是，我不知道你来自哪里，但在我来自的地方，你付给某人12000美元，他们就守海滩。
Cut to a suburban home in the basement.
切到郊区家里的地下室。
Mom, don't come down here.
妈妈，别下来。
What? This is my house.
什么？这是我家。
Ma.
妈。
Don't tell me where I can and cannot go.
别告诉我我可以去哪里，不可以去哪里。
Fine. Just--
行。只要——
What is all of this sand? Cooper!
这些沙子是什么？库珀！
End scene.
场景结束。
Mike Birbiglia, John Lutz, Kate Micucci, Shannon O'Neill, Connor Ratliff, Gary Richardson, and Tami Sagher. Mike, Kate, and Tami are three of the stars of the film that Mike and I just made called Don't Think Twice . It's not a documentary. It's a feature film. It's a comedy about a team of improv comedians and stuff that happens to them. It's in theaters now.
迈克·比尔比利亚、约翰·卢茨、凯特·米库奇、香农·奥尼尔、康纳·拉特利夫、加里·理查森和塔米·萨格。迈克、凯特和塔米是我们刚做的那部电影《不要犹豫》（Don't Think Twice）的三位主演。它不是纪录片。是一部剧情片。这是一部关于一个即兴喜剧演员团队以及发生在他们身上的事情的喜剧。现在影院正在上映。
Coming up, a dad tries something he has never done before, one summer with his family. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一位父亲尝试了他以前从未做过的事，一个与家人的夏天。那会在一分钟后的芝加哥公共广播电台继续节目。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different stories on that theme. Today's show, My Summer Self, stories of who we are during the summer. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, It Takes a Villa.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们每周都会选定一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“我的夏日自我”，讲述我们在夏天时我们是谁。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，别墅的代价。
So sometimes during the summer, people just decide they are going to try and do things they never do, go on some adventure, attempt something, and just see if it takes, see if this is who they are, see if they are the kind of summery person they have never been till now. One of our producers, Neil Drumming, witnessed his dad make an attempt like that.
所以有时在夏天，人们只是决定他们要尝试做他们从来不做的事情，去进行某种冒险，尝试某事，看看它是否合拍，看看这是否是他们的本性，看看他们是否是那种他们直到现在才成为的夏季类型的人。我们的一位制作人，尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming），目睹了他的父亲做出了这样的尝试。
In the summer of 1982, my dad did something unexpected, something that seemed unbelievably indulgent. He took me, my mom, and my brother, and the youngest of my three sisters on the most epic road trip any of us could have possibly imagined at the time. We piled into my dad's Buick Skylark and drove from Queens, New York to the World's Fair in Knoxville, Tennessee, where a robot danced for us, and then down into Orlando, Florida.
1982年的夏天，我父亲做了一件意想不到的事情，一件看起来令人难以置信的放纵的事。他带着我、我妈妈、我哥哥以及我三个姐妹中最小的一个，进行了当时我们所有人能想象到的最史诗级的公路旅行。我们挤进我父亲的别克天际线（Buick Skylark），从纽约皇后区开车前往田纳西州诺克斯维尔的世界博览会，那里有个机器人为我们跳舞，然后一直开到佛罗里达州的奥兰多。
This was a big deal. Before this, going away meant visiting relatives in South Carolina and sitting uncomfortably among aunts and second cousins whose names I would forget before we'd even pulled out of their dusty driveways. This trip was not country heat and sipping sugar water on some rickety porch while listening to the inscrutable conversation of grown folk. It was what going 1,000 miles from home should feel like.
这可是件大事。在这之前，出门意味着去南卡罗来纳州拜访亲戚，在阿姨和堂兄弟姐妹中尴尬地坐着，他们的名字我在离开他们尘土飞扬的车道之前就会忘记。这次旅行不是乡村酷热，坐在某个摇摇欲坠的门廊上喝糖水，同时听着成年人深奥的对话。它应该是离家1000英里的感觉。
We cruised down a brightly lit street called International Drive. We stayed at a Holiday Inn taller and more grand than any I'd ever seen. Sunlight streamed in through a hole in the ceiling, a hole that was supposed to be there.
我们沿着一条叫国际大道（International Drive）的灯火通明的街道行驶。我们住进了一家比我见过的任何酒店都要高大壮观的假日酒店（Holiday Inn）。阳光透过天花板上的洞洒进来，那个洞本来就应该是那样的。
Our parents took us to a building that looked like a pile of poached eggs, but was actually Xanadu, House of the Future. And everywhere, along every roadside, billboards promised that the most magical scene still awaited us, this place, Disney World. By all accounts, it was paradise for kids.
我们的父母带我们去了一栋看起来像一堆荷包蛋的建筑，但实际上那是“上都”（Xanadu），未来之屋。到处都是，在每条路边，广告牌承诺着最神奇的景象仍然在等待着我们，这个地方，迪斯尼乐园（Disney World）。不管从什么方面看，对孩子来说那就是天堂。
But between the gas and the hotels and the eating out, my dad quickly discovered how expensive taking even 60% of his brood on a Disney vacation could be. He was resigned to do it, but he wasn't above working the angles. He found out that you could get cheap tickets to the Magic Kingdom if you just signed up to sit through an hour or so spiel from someone pitching timeshares. He was in.
但在汽油、酒店和餐馆花销之间，我父亲很快发现带他孩子里的60%去迪斯尼度假有多贵。他不得不这样做，但他不是那种不会钻空子的人。他发现如果你只是签下参加一个小时左右推销分时度假的人的推销演说，就可以拿到去魔法王国的廉价门票。他加入了。
The hard sell went down at the Disney Village, a branded mini mall near the famous theme park. My mom, dad, and a handful of other determined parents stowed their kids in a room full of toys that had been conveniently provided by the salespeople. The parents set about the business of listening-- or not-- waiting patiently for the moment when the closers would stop shilling and start handing out the Disney discounts.
强行推销发生在迪斯尼小镇（Disney Village），那个著名主题公园附近的一个品牌迷你商场。我父母和几个其他坚定的父母把孩子们关进了一个满是玩具的房间，这些玩具是销售员方便地提供的。父母们开始听这些话——或者没听——耐心地等待推销员停止推销并开始分发迪斯尼折扣的时刻。
But while we kids were in another room throwing LEGOs at one another, something surprising happened. My dad bit. He went into a closed room to get three-day passes just so that I could eventually lose my glasses on Space Mountain. And he came out with a deed, the deed to something he and my mom were now calling our villa.
但当我们在另一个房间互相扔乐高积木时，发生了一些令人惊讶的事情。我父亲上钩了。他走进一个封闭的房间去买三天通票，只是为了让我最后在“太空山”（Space Mountain）丢掉眼镜。而他出来时拿着一份契据，那是一份他和我妈妈现在称之为我们“别墅”的东西的契据。
My father was a bold man, but in retrospect this is the most impetuous action that I have ever seen him take. It cost him about $5,000, which he paid in installments. In 1982, for a guy with five kids who never made more than $33,000 a year at his day job, it was a considerable investment.
我父亲是个大胆的人，但回想起来，这是我见过他采取的最冲动的行动。它花费了他大约5000美元，他分期付款。在1982年，对于一个有五个孩子，在日常工作中从没赚到超过33000美元一年的人来说，这是一笔相当大的投资。
For those unfamiliar with timeshares, it may be hard to wrap your head around buying a vacation home that you never really own. You pay upfront for it. There's an annual maintenance fee. But you only get to stay in it once a year or so, usually for a week at a time. It almost sounds like some sort of scam. And sometimes it is. But it didn't turn out that way for us. Instead, it became a fixture in my family.
对于那些不熟悉分时度假的人来说，可能很难理解买一个你从未真正拥有的度假屋。你预付费用。有年度维护费。但你一年只能住一次左右，通常一次住一周。听起来几乎像是某种骗局。有时确实如此。但对我们来说并非如此。相反，它成了我家庭生活的一个固定组成部分。
My father had chosen as our week the first week in July. And so every year, during one of the hottest months of the year, we would head down I-95 as always. But now, when we pulled into South Carolina to see relatives, that was only a pit stop on the way to our true destination. We had transformed from people who went away to a family who went on vacation.
我父亲选定的一周是七月的第一周。所以每年，在一年中最热的月份之一，我们就像往常一样沿着95号州际公路南下。但现在，当我们驶入南卡罗来纳州看望亲戚时，那只是前往我们真正目的地的一个中转站。我们从那种“出门去的人”变成了一个“去度假的家庭”。
Our villa was number 317, a two-bedroom apartment with an enclosed back porch that looked out onto a small man-made lake complete with fish and ducks and another summer word that I learned, gazebo. My brother chased cicadas and lizards. For my sister, the only swimmer among my siblings, there was a pool. There were tennis courts and bikes to rent. The general store even offered a collection of the latest movies on laser disc.
我们的别墅是317号，一套两居室公寓，有一个封闭的后廊，可以看到一个人工小湖，里面有鱼、鸭子和我学到的另一个关于夏天的词，“凉亭”。我哥哥追逐蝉和蜥蜴。对于我姐妹中唯一的游泳者，这里有一个泳池。有网球场和租用的自行车。便利店甚至提供了一系列最新的激光影碟电影。
That first trip, I was eight. As I got older, I moved from the gazebo to the game room and then the gym, trying to meet other kids my age. My mom busied herself in the kitchen making lunches or sat by the lake and watched the ducks. My dad shepherded us through It's a Small World and Epcot Center.
那第一次旅行，我八岁。随着我长大，我从凉亭搬到了游戏室，然后是健身房，试着去认识其他同龄的孩子。我妈妈在厨房忙着准备午餐，或者坐在湖边看着鸭子。我父亲引导我们穿过“小小世界”（It's a Small World）和艾普科特中心（Epcot Center）。
Our summers went on like this, pretty much exactly like this, probably until I finished high school. I honestly loved it. I looked forward to this trip every year. And even though it was only a week, it was almost always the highlight of my entire summer.
我们的暑假就这样继续着，几乎完全如此，直到我高中毕业。我真心喜欢它。我每年都期待这次旅行。虽然只有一周，但这几乎总是我整个暑假的亮点。
But when I think about it now, it occurs to me my dad pretty much orchestrated this thing that became so important to our lives. And I have no idea whether or not he ever enjoyed it himself. In fact, it didn't seem like he did. I can't recall actually seeing him happy.
但现在想起它，我意识到我父亲几乎一手导演了这个对我们生活变得如此重要的事情。而我根本不知道他自己是否曾享受过它。事实上，看起来他并没有。我不记得曾见过他开心。
Neither does my brother. He says dad was pretty much the same at the timeshare as he was at home. Sometimes he'd go for walks alone, but often he just sat on the couch and watched TV. I asked my sister. She said he must have been happy, but she doesn't remember witnessing it, either.
我哥哥也不记得。他说父亲在分时度假屋时几乎和他在家时一样。有时他会独自散步，但经常只是坐在沙发上看电视。我问了我姐妹。她说他一定很开心，但她也不记得见过。
It seems like such a simple question, but I just wanted to know. Did he enjoy himself?
这似乎是个简单的问题，但我只是想知道。他自己享受吗？
At the risk of embodying the most tired trope in all of modern masculinity, I will say my father and I never really got along. He was strict. His house had a lot of rules. And he believed in corporal punishment. And the sting of that conflict stayed with me as an adult. But since my mom passed away last year, I've been trying to connect with him more. I gave him a call.
冒着体现现代男子气概中最陈旧比喻的风险，我要说我父亲和我从没真正合得来。他很严厉。他的家有很多规则。他相信体罚。那种冲突的刺痛感一直伴随我到成年。但自从我妈妈去年去世后，我一直试图和他多联系。我给他打了个电话。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
Yes?
是？
Hey, it's Neil.
嘿，是尼尔（Neil）。
Yes.
是。
Is it a bad time?
现在不方便吗？
It's about who?
是关于谁？
I say, is it a bad time?
我说，现在不方便吗？
No. No, I was just playing solitaire. Yeah. I didn't know whether it was the drugstore or not.
不。不，我只是在玩纸牌。是啊。我不知道那是药店还是别的地方。
Are you waiting for a call from the drugstore?
你在等药店的电话吗？
No. They'll call. They'll give me a call no matter when it is.
不。他们会打的。不管什么时候他们都会打给我。
My dad is 83 years old now and living alone in Florida. Talking to him can be awkward and not just because his hearing is going. I asked him point blank if he liked going to the villa. He told me that when he was growing up, he barely ever left South Carolina.
我父亲现在83岁了，独自住在佛罗里达。和他谈话可能会很尴尬，不仅是因为他的听力在衰退。我直截了当地问他是否喜欢去那栋别墅。他告诉我，在他成长过程中，他几乎没离开过南卡罗来纳州。
I didn't know nothing about nothing else. You know, like, you saw things in magazines and stuff. The first time I knew about a dentist I was in the army. But I just thought it was a good idea that our kids see something other than their surroundings and where they were born.
我对其他事一无所知。你知道，就像，你在杂志之类的东西里看到东西。我第一次知道什么是牙医是在军队里。但我只是认为让我们的孩子看到除了他们周围环境以及他们出生地之外的东西是个好主意。
Yeah.
是啊。
My dad grew up poor on a farm, one of 12 children. He says he only finished high school because by the time he was old enough, he was the one driving the bus. Sometimes when there were athletic events at other schools, he'd get to drive the teams and learn what the nearby towns were like.
我父亲在农场贫穷的环境中长大，12个孩子中的一个。他说他只读完了高中，因为在他够大的时候，他就是那个开校车的人。有时当其他学校有体育赛事时，他会去开校车带球队，了解附近的小镇是什么样的。
In 1953, he was drafted into the army, which had only recently been integrated. They sent him to Colorado and Indiana. And it wasn't great. He says the army was really not into black people back then.
1953年，他被征召入伍，当时军队才刚刚废除种族隔离不久。他们把他派往科罗拉多和印第安纳。情况并不好。他说那时的军队真的很不喜欢黑人。
So those were his travel experiences when he was young. I was hearing a lot of this for the first time. As it turns out, that's at least partially my own fault.
所以这就是他年轻时的旅行经历。我很多时候是第一次听到这些。事实证明，至少部分是因为我自己的错。
The reason why we never talk about it because it just wasn't the kind of thing that you guys seemed to be interested in.
我们从不谈论它的原因是因为这似乎不是你们感兴趣的那种事。
Really? So we just didn't seem like we were interested as kids?
真的吗？所以我们小时候看起来对这些不感兴趣？
Yeah. Right.
是啊。对。
Yeah, I probably wasn't so interested back then, back when the two of us were constantly challenging each other. I was always either afraid of him or angry at him, hiding from him or planting my feet to confront him. It never crossed my mind to try to understand him.
是啊，在那时我们经常相互挑战的时候，我可能没那么感兴趣。我要么怕他，要么生他的气，躲着他或者站稳脚跟和他对抗。我从来没想过要去尝试了解他。
But nowadays my dad feels to me like some kind of living cold case, a million-page brief that is no longer redacted. Maybe it's because I'm now at the age he was when I was born, but I retroactively find his every decision fascinating, even the ones that aren't so surprising on the surface.
但如今我父亲对我来说感觉像某种活着悬而未决的案件，一份不再被涂黑的百万页简报。也许是因为我现在到了他生我时的年龄，所以我追溯性地觉得他每一个决定都很迷人，即使是那些表面上看起来并不令人惊讶的决定。
Why Florida?
为什么是佛罗里达？
It was advertised. And you get to hear something about Florida. And then this thing, Disney World. After we started going, they build Epcot. They build Animal Kingdom. And they advertise them a lot.
那是广告宣传的。而且你开始听到一些关于佛罗里达的事。然后这东西，迪斯尼世界。在我们开始去之后，他们建造了艾普科特。他们建造了动物王国。他们做了很多宣传。
Not many people were going. We were probably the most vacationing people in our area. I don't know of any other family that went on vacation every year. We did.
没多少人去。我们可能是我们那个地区最常度假的人了。我不知道有任何其他家庭每年去度假。我们做了。
My dad was obviously proud that he got the timeshare. But pride, strictly speaking, does not constitute joy. It didn't answer the question of whether or not he was actually happy spending those summer weeks with us at the villa. Instead, he kept trying to make me understand why he brought us there in the first place. And his explanation, his reasoning, reached back to memories and past experiences that not only had I never heard, but that kind of blew my mind.
我父亲显然为他拿到分时度假权而自豪。但严格来说，骄傲并不等于快乐。它没有回答他是否真的在别墅和我们共度那些夏日周时感到快乐。相反，他不断试图让我理解他最初为什么把我们带到那里。他的解释，他的推理，回溯到不仅是我从未听过，而且让我大开眼界的记忆和过去的经历。
Now, I tell you, probably where I got the whole idea, when we went to school, every summer you had to try to think of something that you could write about when you go back to school because you're going to have to write something about what you did this summer. Well, we never had anything to write about when I was going to school. And you didn't think plowing a mule, or picking peaches or stuff, that you had to normally do, you didn't think that was so exciting to write about. And so we made up lies about what we did.
现在，我告诉你，大概我从哪儿得来的这个主意，当我们上学时，每年夏天你必须试着想一些东西写下来，当你回到学校时，因为你回到学校后必须写点关于你夏天做了什么。嗯，当我上学时我们从来没有任何可以写的东西。而且你并不认为耕骡子，或者摘桃子之类，那些你通常必须要做的事，你并不认为那是那么令人兴奋可以写出来的。所以我们编造了关于我们做了什么的谎言。
Well, every summer you guys went on vacation, you could write about something that you did or saw or some place you went.
嗯，每年夏天你们去度假时，你们可以写点你们做的或者看到的，或者你们去的什么地方。
Yeah. What did you do during the summers?
是啊。你夏天做了什么？
When? This year?
什么时候？今年？
No, no, when you were in school.
不，不，当你上学时。
Worked. That's what I tried to tell you.
工作。这就是我试着告诉你的。
We talked for over an hour. It was one of the longest conversations that I can remember us ever having. Every now and then, I try to steer him back to the question I wanted him to answer.
我们谈了一个多小时。这是我记得我们之间进行过的最长的谈话之一。时不时地，我试着引导他回到我想要他回答的问题上。
So I know I asked you this a bunch of times. I keep asking you the same question. You can tell me to stop asking you if you want, but did you have fun yourself?
所以我知道我问过你很多次了。我一直问你同一个问题。如果你想让我停下来问你，你可以告诉我不问了，但你自己玩得开心吗？
Yeah. See, I don't regret anything because it looked to me like I was doing what I was supposed to do. And to see your kids happy was to be happy, too. And you guys could always come in and do whatever it is and go back out to the pool or whatever. I remember you guys playing out there and hanging around the bushes and stuff. I thought it was great.
是啊。你看，我不后悔任何事，因为对我来说，看起来我做了我应该做的事。看到你们孩子快乐，我也就快乐了。你们总是可以进来做任何事，然后回到泳池或任何地方。我记得你们在外面玩耍，在灌木丛周围转悠之类的。我觉得那太棒了。
That's the kind of enjoyment I hadn't considered. I live more selfishly. Also, his answer was hard to take in, to reconcile with the distance I felt between us at the time, back when he would retire to the couch to watch TV while we went off to play on our own. Maybe he was watching me play in the bushes and getting a kick out of it. But I didn't know that.
那是种我没考虑过的享受。我活得更自私。而且，他的回答很难接受，很难与当时我感到的我们之间的疏离感调和，那时候他会回到沙发上看电视，而我们去自己玩耍。也许他在看着我在灌木丛里玩耍并从中得到快乐。但我不知道。
Still, I was happy at the villa. And my dad says he was, too. I'm glad I know that.
不过，我在别墅里很开心。我父亲说他也是。我很高兴我知道这点。
All right. So I've been talking to you for an hour. I should probably let you go. But, hey, is it OK if I call back this week and just talk? I want to hear more stuff. Since I didn't seem interested when I was a kid, I didn't realize that was why you didn't tell us stuff. So now I'll just ask. Is that OK if I could--
好的。所以我已经和你聊了一个小时了。我大概应该让你走了。但，嘿，我这个星期可以再打来只是聊聊吗？我想听更多的事。因为我小时候看起来不感兴趣，我没意识到那就是你没告诉我们事的原因。所以现在我会问。如果我可以——这样行吗？
The only thing I'd do is to get up and sometimes I'm outside just walking around. Sometimes I sit down and-- sometimes I go ride the bike. And I do this just to keep busy. You can call me anytime--
我唯一会做的事就是起床，有时我在外面只是四处走走。有时我坐下来，而且——有时我去骑自行车。我这样做只是为了让自己有事做。你可以随时打电话给我——
All right. I'm going to go back to work.
好的。我要回去工作了。
OK.
好的。
Bye, Dad.
再见，爸爸。
Bye.
再见。
Neil Drumming, one of the producers of our show.
尼尔·德拉明，我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC -  "THE HAPPIEST PLACE ON EARTH" BY AJ RAFAEL"]
[音乐——《地球上最幸福的地方》，AJ Rafael演唱]
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming. Our production staff-- Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, David Kestenbaum, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our editor's Joel Lovell. Editorial help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Other staff-- Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Research help from Christopher Swetala Music help from Damien Graef from Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Vicki and Dock Drumming, George Green and The Unchained Tour, and Brooklyn Loft Party. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明制作。我们的制作团队——佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、凯伦·达芬（Karen Duffin）、伊曼纽尔·佐特西（Emmanuel Dzotsi）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔（Joel Lovell）。朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）提供了编辑协助。其他员工——埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）、艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）、金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）和塞思·林德（Seth Lind）。克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）提供了研究协助，达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）提供了音乐协助。今天特别感谢维基和多克·德拉明（Vicki and Dock Drumming）、乔治·格林（George Green）和“Unchained”巡演，以及布鲁克林阁楼派对。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
We've revamped our e-mail newsletter. And if you sign up for it this week, we will send you the photo of me doing a magic trick for Michael Jackson in 1972. We were both 13 years old.
我们改版了我们的电子邮件通讯。如果你本周注册它，我们会发给你那张我1972年为迈克尔·杰克逊表演魔术的照片。我们当时都13岁。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to a program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, or as we like to call him--
一如既往地感谢节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），或者正如我们喜欢叫他的——
--the grape smuggler, the Miami meat tent, the dingaling sling, Saint-Tropez truffle duffle.
——“葡萄偷运者”、“迈阿密肉棚”、“丁丁吊索”、“圣特罗佩松露包”。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。